now we're going to continue our analysis
from before using the data that we
downloaded from the expression values
when your rent RNA seek now we're under
the RNA seek page still the RNA seek map
you want to go up to areas of analysis
to machine learning and and since we
only have a single file we're gonna just
add files rather than a URL book bulk
upload as we did before so our
expression genes and then continue here
and then we push start as before
quantile normalization this is a single
step now from here we can actually end
the analysis run the pipeline or go
straight into pca
and we're going to keep the filter
number one a filter out of 25% max we're
gonna put it into already logged we can
also go straight from from starting and
going to pca without normalization then
you would put no.4 log the normalization
puts it into a log log format you need
to know what column your data ends on to
look at that an excel sheet and so our
last column it is 22 comma data starts
on and that is column 2 but you'll also
see the first column being the list of
both genes
click Save and and again we can type in
PC a test
and then we save everyone and then we go
check the pipeline's and you see it
started but we also have these ones that
I have one for one which I ran
unnormalized data and one which was just
the PCA that we normalized and then did
and here we will and we can download the
gene expression genes normalized or the
PCA results and then from here we go
back into Excel we open the data import
data text file and then we get its or
normalized PCA result and get data and
you will see up here so there's a list
of principal components and you see up
here first principal component contains
most of the variation second contains
the next amount and and down until you
get to the end and you see we have about
31 percent of our variation is accounted
for by the first two principal
components if we take the first two
columns or put a scatterplot and this is
what we will see for the X access being
the first principal component and the y
axis being the second principal
component
and that's it for this part of the
analysis next we will look at the
normalized data and on a cheat